seems like comedians have different
experiences working with like these big
streamers obviously like Andrew Schultz
had the story about buying his back and
you're someone who typically works with
darker jokes and darker topics so was
there anything that Netflix had a
problem with or were they just like the
keys are in your hands I couldn't
believe it I think maybe like a Dave
Chappelle or somebody opened the door
for uh just saying crazy or Ricky
Gervais maybe they were cool with I got
Holocaust Down syndrome you know fat
jokes trans jokes you name it and they
were the only thing they said was I
wouldn't do covet stuff just because
it's it's passed